on va parler mobilité douce à présent et
ça roule pour les trottinettes
électriceses électriques blaisoises on
appelle ça un succès Aurélien lancé à
l'été 2022 la location des trottinettes
électriques a visiblement conquis le
cœur des Blaisois 740 km sont parcourus
chaque jour grâce aux 202 roues
déployées dans la préfecture Loiré
cherrienne une alternative à
l'autosolisme décryptage du
fonctionnement de ce service avec
Clémence Dosque en J de 2022 la ville de
bois lance un service de location de
trottinette électrique un an et demi
plus tard quel bilan tiré du déploiement
de ces 250 de roues pourquoi ça
fonctionne à bois est-ce que ça pourrait
fonctionner à tour c'est la question du
jour 60 zones de stationnement définies
à travers la ville les parcs cimetières
et jardins inaccessibles interdiction de
rouler sur le trottoir l'utilisation de
la trottinette est évidemment réglementé
en une année 30 verbalisation dressé
majoritairement des personnes roulant PL
à de une infraction réévaluée à 135 €
d'amende qu'il faut pas faire c'est
exactement ce que nous on fait monter à
de sur une trtinette ça peut être très
dangereux et respecter le code de la
route parce que ouais franchement oui on
s'arrête après on est très même si on
est deux on respectenmement le code de
la route et limitation de vitesse les
choses comme ça quoi parce que sinon ça
devient super dangereux après on peut
avoir des accidents un côté écolo et
pratique on peut circuler facilement on
a des c'est bien équipé il y a les
clignotants donc c'est homologué pour la
route les automobilistes ils s'en
foutent un peu on passe ils passe tant
qu'on les fait tant qu'on les embête pas
il nous embête pas depuis septembre de
nouveaux modèles ont fait leur
apparition des trottinettes mieux
équipées pour mieux s'intégrer à la
circulation
blaisoise on a les freins avant freins
arrière niveau sécurité c'est c'est
mieux ensuite on a des des clignotants
tout ce qui est clignotant signalisation
ensuite on a des accessoires comme le
post téléphone ce qui va nous permettre
de poser le téléphone en sécurité et
puis de le recharger en même temps
nouvelle alternative à l'autosolisme les
trottinettes sont surtout utilisé sur
les trajets domicile travail la flotte
cumule jusqu'à 295 voyages par jour sur
un an on a 108000 trajets qui ont été
effectués avec 270000 km de kilomètr
parcourus pardon et et donc c'est plutôt
plutôt quelque chose de très positif
donc je répète encore une fois ça coûte
rien du tout à la ville de Blois et on
gagne plutôt sur les aires de
stationnement et une occupation du
domaine public plus d'un an après leur
mise en service les trottinettes
blaisoises ont trouvé leur public une
offre en complément des bus qui permet
de relier le sud et le nord en un temps
record